we have multi-passions we feel like
we're everywhere we're chasing shiny
objects we're comparing ourselves to
others what are your tips for getting
clear number one on the vision so the
challenge with social media today is
there's so many different people right
there's so many different influencers
and some have a different style I had a
guy the other they asked me a question
they said hey should I drop f-bombs
because I see some people who do and
it's working out well for them I said
what do you mean drop f-bombs because
maybe that's why I'm not getting any
subscribership I said that's not why
you're not getting subscribership okay
you don't need to start cursing people
are not coming for that who do you
relate to like who is you when you watch
everybody who is you and what is your
area of expertise for us we sat there
and I said this is how I talk this is
how I tell my stories this is my style
of communication this is what I know a
lot about this is what we want to go to
next here's where I see the Market's
lacking and then this is us we're
sticking to here